We're promised that the input function f is either constant or balanced, and the goal is to figure
out which one it is.
And we're not responsible for what happens if the input
doesn't meet the promise.
The Deutsch-Jozsa algorithm,
which solves this problem, is first to run the Deutsch-Jozsa circuit and then output 0
if the string that we
obtain from the measurements is the all-zero string
and output 1 otherwise.
Another way to say that is that we output the OR of
the bits that we measure.
To analyze the Deutsch-Jozsa algorithm, it'll be helpful to
first take a few moments to think about Hadamard gates.
We can, of course, describe the Hadamard
operation as a matrix, but we can also describe
it in terms of its action
on standard basis states,
as you see right here.
These two equations can be
combined into a single equation, which describes how a
Hadamard operation works for a being either of
the two binary values,
and we can go a little bit further and express what we
obtain as a sum like this.
Using that formula, we can come up with a formula that describes how a layer
of Hadamard gates works, where we apply one Hadamard
gate to each of n qubits.
Here we're describing this
action on standard basis states.
And to be clear about the notation, when we write h tensor n like this, where the tensor n part is a superscript,
what we mean is the n fold
tensor product of H with itself, or in other words, n copies
of h all tensor together.
We're applying this operation
to a standard basis state, and here I'm following the
convention that Qiskit uses
to index binary strings, just because it's a good time
to introduce that convention.
So x0 is a bit, x1 is a bit,
and so on with n bits in total, and the bits are ordered as
you see here on the screen.
You can think about this
way of indexing bits as corresponding to their significance if we view strings as
representing integers
in binary notation, for instance.
If we apply a Hadamard gate
to each of these qubits, we can alternatively express the result as the n fold tensor product
of a Hadamar gate applied to each qubit, and then we can apply our formula to each one of the tensor factors.
And here we're using the
names y and minus 1 down to y1 in place of b in the formula,
so these are binary values. And we're making sure to use a new name each time we use the formula.
If we then expand everything out using the multilinearity
of tensor products, we get the expression
that you see right here.
And to be clear, the n sums are being
combined into a single sum, but we're still summing
over all the possible values
for the individual binary values.
Now let's clean things up so that we can go a little bit further.
And the next step is to
introduce a new operation on strings called the binary dot product.
This is an operation on binary strings having the same length.
And what the binary dot product of two strings x and y
of the same length is, is the eXclusive OR or the parity
of the products of the individual bits.
You could also say that it's the XOR of the logical and of the individual bits, because the and is the
same thing as the product
for binary values. Yet another way to describe
it is that it's 1 or 0
depending on whether
the sum of the products of the individual bits is odd or even.
It's very much like an inner product if we think about strings
as vectors of binary values, but where we compute Modulo-2,
or in other words, we take the remainder after dividing by 2.
It's not really an inner product though, so it deserves a different name.
In the case at hand, we can use the binary dot
product to make our formula for the action of a layer of Hadamard gate
on standard basis states more succinct, and here it is right here.
We're using the fact that
because this sum right here is appearing in the
exponent of negative 1,
all that matters is whether
or not it's even or odd, but otherwise, it's basically just a condensed
version of our formula.
By the way, the binary
dot product is symmetric in the sense that x dot
y and y dot x are equal,
so we are free to swap the
ordering whenever that's useful.
And now that we have that formula, it'll be pretty easy to analyze
the Deutsch-Jozsa circuit.
We start out with n qubits in the 0 state and the bottom qubit in the 1 state, and we perform Hadamard
gates on all of them.
So this is the state of the
n + 1 qubits that we get.
We are treating the
bottom qubit separately because that's gonna be convenient.
And again, we're gonna see the phase
kickback phenomenon happening.